لم تتوقف روسيا عن ضرب منشات تصدير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه منذ انسحابها من اتفاق تصدير
الحبوب في منتصف الشهر الماضي يستمر هذا
القصف رغم اعلان موسكو استعدادها للعوده
للاتفاق بشروط في بيان بعد اتصال هاتفي
بين الرئيسين الروسي والتركي اكد الكرملين
استعداده للعوده فورا الى اتفاق تصدير
الحبوب اذا نفذ الغرب كل التزاماته لروسيا
اذا تترك روسيا الباب مفتوحا للعوده الى
اتفاق تصدير الحبوب لكنها لم تتوقف عن ضرب
البنيه التحتيه التي ستحتاج اليها
اوكرانيا لتصدير حبوبها اذا جرى احياء
الاتفاق تركزت الهجمات مباشره بعد انسحاب
روسيا من الاتفاق على اهم موانئ اوكرانيا
على البحر الاسود وخصوصا ميناء اوديسا
الاستراتيجي ثم بدات في ضرب موانئ بديله
على نهر الدانوب فقاسفت ميناء في الرابع
والعشرين من الشهر الماضي والان تقصف بناء
اسماعيل ما تسبب حسب السلطات الاوكرانيه
في اتلاف اربعين الف طن من الحبوب تقول
كياف ان هدف موسكو من هذه الهجمات واقناع
شركات السفن وشركات التامين ان كل الموانئ
الاوكرانيه غير امنه لكن السلطات
الاوكرانيه تؤكد استمرارها في البحث عن
بدائل لموانئها في البحر الاسود المحاصره
من قبل روسيا تشكل الموانئ الاوكرانيه على
نهر الدانوب الذي يقع على حدود اوكرانيا
ورومانيا افضل البدائل رغم ان مياه النهر
الضحله مقارنه بمياه البحر الاسود تستدعي
استخدام سفن اصغر وباعداد اكبر تنقل
الحبوب من الموانئ النهريه الاوكرانيه على
الدنوب الى ميناء كونستانتا الروماني على
البحر الاسود في عام 2022 صدرت 8 ملايين
الف طن من الحبوب الاوكرانيه عبر الميناء
الروماني لم يتوقف بحث اوكرانيا عن
البدائل فقد اعلن الاوكراني اتفاقا مع
كرواتيا بشان امكانيه تصدير الحبوب عبر
موانئ كرواتيا على الدانوب وبحر
الادرياتيك ورغم دورها المحدود وعرقله
استخدامها من قبل الفلاحين الاوروبيين
الرافدين لاستقبال الحبوب الاوكرانيه تبقى
الطرق البريه بديلا اخر لتصدير حبوب
اوكرانيا لكن هذه البدائل وان تعددت لا
تغني عن البحر الاسود الذي يبقى اسهل
الطرق واقلها تكلفه لتصدير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه